[Music]
if you think classic and vintage cars
should be respected you're probably not
going to like Jonathan ward most
restorers see this is the ultimate goal
getting cars back to their showroom
state not ward he believes they should
be driven and that they should be given
modern engines and controls so that
using and abusing them is enjoyable
[Music]
so you want to keep this design you want
to keep this character let's call it but
you want to incorporate some modern
elements as well what we've seen is more
more people go you know what I'm totally
down with the look and the vibe and the
style but I have absolutely no
attachment to the archaic mechanical
realities so my idea is you take the
static and design principle and then
re-engineer it and infuse it with the
best of modern suspension modern brakes
modern powertrain if we were sensible we
wouldn't make modern cars so fragile so
easy to ding or to get dirty
we just let them look like this and
that's what Ward's company icon does
this workshop just outside LA houses
specialists at making cars look like
they haven't been touched they leave
them in that just found in a barn state
stop by telling us a little bit about
the history of this car
total burn fine this is a 1935 Auburn a
Phaeton which was a common term for a
four-door convertible the purity in the
design and the perspective of the
original designer is so clearly embodied
in everything the concept of suicide
doors are just genius the excursions
with this beautiful taper this enameling
on the dash and the font it just gets me
all excited this patina is just stupid
it's just an amazing art you know that
time and nature created you can't
reproduce woods famous in the car
community for restoring and drastically
upgrading four by fours like the classic
Toyota Landcruiser
now he's working on what he calls
derelicts of course there is the small
matter of cost these distressed looking
vehicles typically sell for more than a
perfect one and easily in the hundreds
of thousands now Ward is experimenting
with adding electric motors instead of
engines to some of his builds
this is the one I'm particularly drawn
to you though a Rolls Royce from my home
country it's a 1958 silver cloud
basically then you've saved the body
panels yeah and everything else correct
so this underside if we're going to get
down yeah how'd you bring in a car and
build a whole new chassis for it and
have it fit you basically shell the car
liberate the shell from the original
chassis get it out of the way then you
prep it clean it and market for laser
mapping so British classic - American
classic a novela have 46 old 1946
original paint killer patina there's no
structural rust now - a lot of people
this wouldn't look like a done car look
at the finish on this part of the fun so
jump in here point out some of the best
bits to me everyone wants power windows
nowadays but an ugly modern power window
switch just can't compare with the grace
and beauty of this so what we've done is
we've developed a module where you now
tap for down and tap built in sleepers
yeah walk built-in steering wheel we
can't abandon this lovely original
design but for ergonomics and for safety
we want a collapsible tilt adjustable
column so we get all that functionality
there so traditionally you would put a
modern drivetrain in each of these
vehicles that you're working on as well
so a modern engine modern gearbox make
them very drivable machines but I mean
the future is electric you know ticket
Tesla's so they're fast they're fun and
everything but I want something with
more distinction more individual more
personality so it brings us at our last
car we want to talk about
[Music]
49 mercury car games he made famous back
in the day just Americana as it gets
original pink car so we're building this
to be a Tesla meter so it's running dual
AMR electric motors about 800
foot-pounds of torque I want to see this
in this condition with its patina and
everything else at the stoplight with a
Tesla
I can't we can we drive one of these
vehicles if we got one that's actually
oh yeah let's go to Wow cool
this custom 1952 Chrysler Town and
Country slash DeSoto wagon is Ward's
private car and it embodies his
philosophy perfectly its unique its
patinaed and its terrifyingly quick it's
the ultimate sleeper classic that could
beat many modern cars away from the
stoplights
you